et sans détour le ministre de la santé
xavier bertrand répond à nos questions
au mont soir merci d'être avec nous
alors vous misez sur des mesures que
vous jugez incitatives pour attirer les
jeunes médecins dans les zones
médicalement déserté est ce que vous
pensez vraiment que une consultation
pays 24 heures au lieu de 20 et propre
justement les attirer oui bien sûr parce
que c'est important comme on l'a vu dans
le reportage c'est de favoriser
l'exercice en groupe parce que quand il
y a plusieurs médecins ou quand il y a
des médecins une infirmière un kiné eh
bien on se partage le travail est
aujourd'hui le principal défi dans les
zones sous médicalisées en campagne mais
aussi dans des banlieues c'est partager
le travail et d'avoir la possibilité de
souffler un peu de se former ou de
passer plus de temps avec les patients
mais en quoi les médecins seront mieux
dispatcher tout simplement parce que il
y a toujours un examen qui sera fait
pour les internes c'est à dire le même
examen les mêmes questions partout sur
le territoire
mais ce qui est important c'est
qu'ensuite on tienne compte des besoins
de chaque région
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il ya
deux régions qui sont en quelque sorte
aux antipodes la région ile de france où
il ya plus de 460 médecin pour 100000
habitants et la région picardie là il ya
deux cent cinquante quatre médecins pour
cent mille habitants
eh bien il faut rectifier le tir il faut
avoir des médecins bien répartis sur
tout le territoire
mais je ne crois pas l'obligation si
vous mettez en place une obligation pour
s'installer dans telle ou telle région
non seulement ça ne marche pas avant dix
ans mais en plus d'être certain que vous
n'aurez même plus les médecins
nécessaires parce qu'il y aura une crise
des vocations
tous les pays qui ont voulu obliger se
sont trompés ça n'a pas marché mais
pourtant les mesures incitatives par le
passé n'ont pas marché non plus n'y a
jamais vraiment une mesure incitative
on en a beaucoup parlé on en a proposé
une de ci de là
alors que là pour la première fois le
plan est globale lepron plan le plan
prend tout en compte d'une part avoir
plus de médecins le numerus clausus à
dire le nombre de médecins formés qui
donc s'installeront a été augmenté de 50
% en quatre ans et là nous nous
engageons sur les cinq années qui
viennent à ce que ce numerus clausus
soit de 7000 par an et puis aussi un
autre aspect c'est qu'en intervenant et
pourquoi pas à l'augmenter parce que il
nous faut aussi voir les paramédicaux
parce que quand on parle seulement des
médecins on oublie qu'avec les
délégations de tâches les délégations de
compétence et vient nous pour demain
voir décliner les infirmiers les
infirmières qui pourront prendre aussi
le relais
les médecins mais en attendant que ce
numerus clausus ne produit ses effets ce
qui m'intéresse aussi c'est de donner
envie aux médecins retraités de rester
en activité
voilà pourquoi à partir de 60 ans les
gars ne seront plus obligatoire les
médecins pourront les prendre mais ce
sera plus une obligation et ça sur tout
le territoire et à partir de 65 ans
aujourd'hui les médecins partent en
retraite à 65 66 ans ils pourront
cumuler leur retraite et un revenu
d'activité
je voudrais qu'on revient dans un
instant sur le numerus clausus parce que
la population est de plus en plus âgée
vit de plus en plus longtemps surtout
les chiffres de l'insee ont été publiés
il ya à peine quelques jours comment
va-t-on pouvoir répondre à la demande
médicale en augmentant notamment le
nombre de médecins voilà pourquoi nous
avons augmenté ce numerus clausus aussi
en transmettant des tâches à d'autres
professionnels de santé aux édiles les
kinés par exemple les infirmières qui
vont pouvoir prescrire qui vont pouvoir
faire notamment du suivi des malades
chroniques et puis également avec un
autre aspect qui est très important
c'est de leur donner vraiment envie et
les moyens de s'installer
on a parlé des cabinets groupe mais un
médecin qui est tout seul qui ne peut
pas se regrouper parce qu'il n'a pas de
confrères à côté de chez lui lui aussi
pourra avoir cette valorisation de la
consultation mais seulement cette
valorisation jouera quand il prendra un
remplaçant parce que ce que veulent les
médecins c'est pouvoir disposer d'un
remplaçant une chose est importante pour
le patient ça sera le même prix c'est
l'assurance maladie qui fera la
différence
mais le patient comme la mutuelle ne
verrons aucun changement merci beaucoup
vous avez bertrand d'avoir répondu à nos
questions